thanks to skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learn to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
attorney general william barr wrote a
four-page summary of the mueller report
here are the nine reasons i don't think
it makes any sense
[Music]
hey legal eagles today we're talking
about the bar letter this is not the
mueller report as a lot of people have
reported this is a summary of the
mueller report as conveyed by the
attorney general
the bar letter purports to summarize the
findings of special counsel robert
mueller
and his investigation into the trump
campaign and potential ties to
russian interference with our election
when the bar letter came out on sunday i
like many americans read it cover to
cover
but there were a couple things that
stuck out to me as an attorney that just
didn't make any sense so here are the
nine things that i don't think make any
sense in the bar letter
number one why does the bar letter only
cover two of the three facets of the
mueller report you might recall that
robert mueller was tasked with
investigating three things
a criminal investigation into potential
ties with russia
a criminal investigation into potential
obstruction of justice by the president
and number three a counterintelligence
investigation
into russian interference with the
american election
but the bar letter only deals with two
of the three facets
of the mueller report and doesn't
actually deal with the
counterintelligence portions of
the mueller investigation why is that
information missing
from barr's letter barr could have
easily provided a summary of the
counterintelligence portion of the
investigation
but for some reason he chose not to why
is that information
not there and we also learned that barr
is going to make a
separate summary that can only be given
to the gang of eight instead of the
full intelligence committees of the
house and the senate so
why is there information that can only
be provided to the gang of eight
when a summary even a top level summary
can't be provided in the letter that is
released to congress in general and to
the american people number two
what does barr mean when he says that
the mueller report quote
did not establish end quote a conspiracy
with the russians what does it mean to
not establish
in this context the bar letter quotes a
portion of the mueller report stating
that
the investigation did not establish that
members of the trump campaign conspired
or coordinated
with the russian government in its
election interference activities
the problem is that this phrase can mean
wildly different things
does it mean that there was no evidence
at all or does it mean that there is a
boatload of evidence but there is not
quite enough to meet the standard of
beyond a reasonable
doubt that is necessary for a criminal
prosecution if a prosecutor says that an
investigation
did not establish something it doesn't
mean that that thing did not happen
it doesn't even mean that the prosecutor
doesn't think it happened
it means that the investigation didn't
produce enough information to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt in front of a
jury that that thing
happened so in this particular context
we don't know which of those potential
outcomes there is is it that there is
absolutely no evidence
or that there is evidence but not quite
enough to meet the legal standard for a
criminal prosecution the difference
between those two things
is incredibly large and is very
important as it regards what congress is
supposed to do next with this
investigation number three
why does barr suggest that there can be
no obstruction of justice
when there isn't a conviction for an
underlying crime attorney general barr
suggests in his letter that you cannot
have
a conviction of obstruction of justice
when there is no
underlying criminal act or conviction
for an underlying criminal act
but that's simply not the case a
conviction for an underlying criminal
act
is not necessary for a conviction of
obstruction of justice just talk to
martha stewart
barry bonds bill clinton or kwame
kilpatrick
the last example is especially
illustrative because former detroit
mayor kwame kilpatrick went to jail
for obstruction of justice in 2008 after
he lied under oath about having an
extramarital affair
having an affair is not an illegal act
but it's often embarrassing
especially for politicians and they can
go to jail for obstructing justice to
prevent that information from coming out
this is especially worrying
because barr wrote a now famous perhaps
infamous 19-page memo
laying out a very idiosyncratic view of
obstruction of justice
in the 19-page memo barr opined that
quote the president's motive in removing
comey and commenting on flynn could not
have been
corrupt unless the president and his
campaign were actually guilty of
illegal collusion the vast majority of
legal scholars agree that this is simply
not the case
that even in the absence of an actual
guilty
verdict of illegal collusion or
conspiracy or coordination
that is not necessary as a predicate for
obstructing justice
into that investigation but that brings
me to point number four
why does attorney general barr think
that there was no crime
even taking attorney general barr's
idiosyncratic view of obstruction of
justice at face value
even so there was crime that was found
in the mueller investigation and
throughout the investigations into the
president president trump is effectively
an unindicted co-conspirator
in a felony campaign finance violation
with michael cohen
hiding or at least preventing the
investigation into that
embarrassing affair and illegal conduct
is more than enough reason to obstruct
justice and can give rise to the
corrupt mental state necessary to be
guilty of obstruction of justice
potentially that investigation was
farmed out to the southern district of
new york but even still
that is potential criminal conduct that
could give rise to obstruction of
justice not to mention all the other
convictions of
papadopoulos manafort and flynn so the
question is why would barr
or mueller himself limit the crime at
issue to
the very narrow definition of russian
conspiracy
that was talked about in the bar letter
i don't think that makes any sense which
takes me to point number five
why didn't robert mueller decide the
obstruction issue
the bar letter states that quote after
making a
thorough factual investigation into
these matters the special counsel
considered whether to evaluate the
conduct under department standards
governing prosecution and declination
decisions
but ultimately determined not to make a
traditional prosecutorial judgment
the special counsel therefore did not
draw a conclusion one way or the other
as to whether the examined conduct
constituted obstruction
that doesn't sound like robert mueller
declined to prosecute because of the
facts
or that there wasn't enough evidence but
because of some countervailing legal
issue
perhaps because of the doj policy not to
indict the sitting president but the bar
letter goes on to state that
instead for each of the relevant actions
investigated the report
sets out evidence on both sides of the
question and leaves unresolved
what the special counsel views as
difficult decisions of law and fact
concerning whether the president's
actions and intent could be viewed as
obstruction
to me that doesn't make any sense if the
facts were 50 50 what we call equipoise
in the law
that doesn't meet the standard of beyond
a reasonable doubt when there is some
evidence
but not enough to reach the very high
standard of beyond a reasonable doubt
then a prosecutor declines to prosecute
in fact mueller apparently did exactly
this
with the collusion coordination and
conspiracy investigation
which barr summarizes as finding that
mueller did not find enough evidence to
establish
those crimes so why did robert mueller
punt
on the obstruction question but not on
the collusion
and conspiracy question which brings me
to the next point point number six
why did william barr weigh in on the
obstruction issue william barr
is a recent political appointee by
president trump
the point of the special counsel statute
was for a neutral party to investigate
the executive branch
if robert mueller found enough evidence
to convict
someone for obstruction of justice the
bar letter appears to state
that robert mueller did not decline to
prosecute for obstruction of justice
because there wasn't enough evidence
but because of some other legal issue
then does that mean that robert mueller
intended for william barr to weigh in
on the question or did robert mueller
intend for congress to answer this
question
was it intended to be teed up for
congress to make that decision
declining to make a quote traditional
prosecutorial decision
is not necessarily inviting the
political appointee william barr to make
that decision
and on top of that robert mueller as
special counsel has exclusive
jurisdiction
in this matter why did he decide not to
move forward with
the obstruction prosecution we know that
when robert mueller does not find enough
evidence to prosecute he
makes a decision not to prosecute but
here in the context of obstruction of
justice
robert mueller is refusing to make any
decision whatsoever we will only know
what that means when the full mueller
report
is revealed and on top of that how is it
possible that william barr can make this
decision
in 48 hours when robert mueller couldn't
make the decision
in two years and was william barr even
able to review
all of the underlying evidence in this
case we don't even know how long the
mueller report itself actually is
which brings me to point number seven
whose legal conclusions are these
and are there other legal conclusions
that we haven't seen yet the bar letter
only purports to convey mueller's
top-line findings and does not include
any of the underlying evidence or legal
analysis that undergirds those findings
the bard letter talks about the two
quote principle findings of the mueller
report
but does that mean that there are other
legal findings that mueller concluded
that
are not part of these top-line findings
and as to the legal conclusions that we
have
we don't know whether attorney general
barr concluded that the president did
not obstruct justice as a factual matter
or that it wasn't legally possible for
him to have obstructed justice
again going back to barr's unsolicited
19-page memo
he argued a minority position that a
president effectively cannot obstruct
justice when it comes to using his
article ii
power and barr also argued that the
obstruction of justice statutes don't
apply to the president
because they do not specifically mention
the president if attorney general barr
imputed those minority legal positions
onto robert mueller in the investigation
then it was effectively impossible as a
logical matter
for the president to have conducted
obstruction of justice which brings me
to point number eight
why did barr quote the portion of the
mueller report that states that
the mueller report does not exonerate
the president the bar
letter is potential partisan
whitewashing we don't know what's in the
underlying report
and we don't know how accurate of a
summary the bar letter actually is
it's possible that barr is intentionally
setting the narrative
before the full muller report comes out
but even still
why include this cherry-picked phrase
that is actually detrimental to the
president stating that the mueller
report does not
in fact exonerate the president if a
report or evidence doesn't exonerate
someone from a crime
and you're writing a summary about it
you don't have to include a sentence
that says
the report does not exonerate that
person you can just leave it at the fact
that
the crime was not established or that
the decision was made
not to prosecute you don't have to go to
the extra step and say that it doesn't
exonerate that person it seems like an
odd inclusion in this very
high level summary of the mueller report
which takes me to point number nine
which may be the most baffling thing
about the bar letter and
potentially the mueller report itself
which is that there was a decision made
not to prosecute for obstruction of
justice
but that decision was made without
interviewing the president
was there an effort to actually
interview the president we know that
under past precedent under the clinton
versus jones affair
and also the star investigation into
president clinton
that the president can be made to stand
for an interview
was an effort to get president trump to
stand for an interview made
and on top of that why allow the
president to offer written answers to
written questions
in lieu of an actual oral examination
obstruction of justice requires proving
that the defendant
had a corrupt motive in conducting the
acts
that constitute the obstruction of
justice the best way to determine that
is to interview the defendant now
potentially the defendant can take the
fifth amendment but here
given that the best evidence one way or
the other
is going to come from the president
about his motivations in taking
these different actions why was the
president not
interviewed in this investigation now
that the investigation
is done attorney general barr is going
to have to read through thousands of
pages of the mueller report to determine
what can be publicly released he could
really benefit from a speed reading
class to get through the full muller
report quickly
like silvio mariska's skillshare class
on speed reading which could teach barr
to triple his reading speed in seven
days silvio's class could teach barr how
to read the mueller report at a thousand
words per minute
and at the same time improve his reading
comprehension and retention
at that rate we might actually see the
mueller report before the next
presidential election skillshare is an
online learning community that has over
20
000 classes on everything like lifestyle
design technology business you name it
the first 500 legal eagles will get two
free months of skillshare when you click
on the link below the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must-know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things
so click on the link get two free months
and start learning to think like a
lawyer today
it could even help you read the mueller
report and figure out why he refused to
make the call
on obstruction do you agree leave your
objections in the comments
and check out my other real law reviews
over here
where i will see you in court